WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME,
UNFAPPABLE.
THE INTERNET HAS CONNECTED LOST
RELATIVES AND HELPED TOPPLE
REGIMES.
BUT, MAINLY, YOU USE IT TO JERK
OFF.
SOMETIMES THOUGH, ON THE SEARCH
FOR A GOOD WANK ROLL, YOU
INADVERTENTLY STUMBLE UPON THAT
SMALL PORTION OF THE WEB THAT IS
NOT PORN AT ALL.
WHAT? FOR EXAMPLE, YOU MIGHT
TYPE IN "ASIAN FACIAL" AND YOU
GET THIS.
NO!
SO, COMEDIANS, I'M GONNA SHOW
YOU A...
(NATASHA LAUGHING)
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU A SERIES OF
ANNOYINGLY INNOCENT IMAGES, AND
I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME THE PORN
SEARCH TERMS THAT ACCIDENTALLY
LED YOU THERE.
I'M GONNA START THE CLOCK RIGHT
NOW.
FIRST ONE. HUH?
(BELL DINGS)
ANDY.
>> ARYAN MOMS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
(BELL DINGS)
NATASHA.
>> BLONDE WITH NO GAG REFLEX.
>> HARDWICK: OH!
AMAZING!
POINTS!
SO MANY POINTS.
N-NEXT ONE.
(BELL DINGS)
NATASHA.
>> FOUR-MONTH-OLD GETS A
MOUTHFUL.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
(GROANING, LAUGHTER)
NEXT ONE. HUH, HUH?
WHAT IS... ANDY.
>> THINGS STICKING TO TITS.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, P...
POINTS.
NEXT ONE...
(BELL DINGS)
NATASHA.
>> STEPDAD BATHROOM SURPRISE.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
MM-HMM. YEP.
(BELL DINGS)
THERE'S THIS ONE. ANDY DALY.
>> (BLEEP)ABLE SUCCULENTS.
>> HARDWICK: LAST ONE HERE.
(BELL DINGS)
DEREK.
>> DAVY (BLEEP)ETT.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, POINTS. YEAH.
YEAH, YEAH, DEFINITELY.